it wasn't the corporate Espionage
Scandal the alleged laundering of drug
money or the private banking fraud that
brought down Credit Suisse in the end it
was a five-word interview response from
its biggest investor I'm wondering
whether you would be open to assisting
further if there was another call for
additional liquidity from Credit Suisse
the answer is absolutely not in other
words if Credit Suisse needed propping
up financially it couldn't count on the
Saudis investors panicked that the bank
would collapse and Spark a new Global
crisis it was the culmination of years
of missteps and misconduct that showed
what it had failed to learn from the
last financial crisis namely don't take
unnecessary risks with your clients
money
as power Brokers politicians and
Executives scrambled to avert
catastrophe the 166 year old pillar of
Swiss Finance would be corralled into a
deal that almost no one really wanted
deal done UBS will buy Credit Suisse for
three billion Swiss Francs truly
historic this ends 166-year run for
Credit Suisse that Bell is for the
demise of Credit Suisse the birth of a
new bank and a whole new view on Swiss
banking
foreign
for Credit Suisse and its investors to
swallow for most of its history it was
bigger and more successful than UBS a
Mainstay of Swiss success the bank's
painful and very public demise is a blow
to the Alpine nation's reputation for
stability discretion and reliability
this had been seen as one of the banks
that built the nation essentially they
made their their star as a way to
finance railroads in Switzerland and
from there it had it just grows and
grows into this economic Powerhouse
fueling the nation's economic economy
itself but also making it a global
economy it scraped through the global
financial crisis without a government
bailout unlike UBS by 2015 however signs
emerged that it had an unhealthy
Appetite For What the financial crisis
was supposed to have reduced risk the
acquisition of first Boston in the 1980s
had given it a sizeable U.S Investment
Banking presence but its private banking
arm was the initial source of its
problems there was the Geneva employee
who dipped into the funds of super rich
clients to cover losses made on other
accounts for instance and the 2022
conviction for having failed to prevent
money laundering by a drugs ring which
Credit Suisse is appealing as those
Affairs chipped away at the bank's
reputation the CEO became embroiled in a
corporate Espionage Scandal that would
ultimately lead to his departure look
it's been a difficult period of course
for the bank a lieutenant of CEO to John
ATM had hired a surveillance team to
watch a former executive who had left to
join arch rival UBS while there's no
indication that tiam himself knew of any
wrongdoing it made tabloid headlines
while hardly a good look none of this
had any meaningful impact on the
company's bottom line
that changed in 2021
in early March Credit Suisse gets caught
up in the insolvency of green seal
Capital through which it had funneled
billions of dollars of loans to less
than sound borrowers but it was nothing
compared to what would come barely two
weeks later
a sudden multi-billion dollar
liquidation of stocks held by arcados
Capital this after the little-known firm
a former hedge fund manager Bill Wang
defaulted on margin loans while some
lenders like Goldman Sachs and Wells
Fargo were able to cover their exposure
other Banks including credit Swiss and
nomura are said to be facing impairments
this collapses and this causes a 5.5
billion dollar loss for the bank the two
events essentially ripped apart the bank
at its scenes every time it came back to
a question of what is management doing
the losses wiped out a Year's worth of
profit TM successors CEO Thomas
gotchstein had been elevated from
running the successful Swiss domestic
Bank to clean up the firm's reputation
those efforts were now in tatters the
shares started tumbling and never really
recovered as Financial losses widened
got Stein 2 was replaced in August 2022
and the bank had its third CEO in as
many years
he had this nickname
allegedly
Uli the knife being very kind of cost
cutting focus and very cold actually
with how to deal with a business in
crisis it kind of starts a turnaround
plan he'll ditch the first Boston
Investment Banking business and he
brings in a major new investor Saudi
National Bank tobacco's plan even so the
market remains tense
at this stage when the bank is so
fragile that when a tweet hits just
hinting at the potential collapse of a
bank everyone assumes its credit space
and that sets off a panic in the markets
shares the bonds and clients Panic a lot
of clients decide to remove all their
money from credit SUVs and you end up
with the quarter finishing with 110
billion dollars worth of assets out the
door that was almost a third of all
deposits it wasn't exactly a bank run
but it was a massive outflow of capital
in the space of just one fiscal quarter
then March comes One stock to watch for
all of you it's svbig shares syncing
this is a classic Bank Run and when the
blank run starts you don't want to be
the last guy in there svb Bank closed
closed
by the regulator the stocks Europe 600
then being dragged down by the financial
services sector by the banking sector
down by 2.75 with banking stocks already
depressed by the Californian bank's
troubles on March the 14th Credit Suisse
announced it has found quote material
weaknesses in its reporting and control
structures after questions were raised
by U.S Regulators Kerner tries to Stave
off investor concern so svb as you know
is a very recent
thing which happened over weekend
yesterday so far it's pretty calm
um we even saw material good inflows
yesterday still one day later the
chairman of Saudi National Bank sits
down for an interview with Bloomberg TV
at a conference in Riyadh the Saudi
Capital I'm wondering whether you would
be open to assisting further if there
was another call for additional
liquidity from Credit Suisse the answer
is absolutely not for many reasons
outside the simplest reason which is
Regulatory and statuary we now own
9.8 of the bank if we go above 10 all
kinds of new rules kick in after the
Saudi National Bank Chairman's comments
they are just watching their stock going
to free fall and not only that they're
also watching their bonds trade lower
Axel Lehmann the Credit Suisse chairman
and kerners boss happened to be at the
same conference so he's rushing back
from Riyadh to connect with his
management team in credit SUVs at the
headquarters Missouri Corrado flats and
they essentially get in to a virtual war
room to discuss okay what are our
options we need to do something about
this because if we let the market
continue our debt's going to go to zero
value and our Shares are going to go to
zero value Credit Suisse said early that
Thursday it intended to borrow up to 54
billion dollars from the Swiss National
Bank the effort to car market fairs is
actually just a Gambit to buy time
the regulator has lost patience with the
bank and wants to find a buyer what
ensued was deal making at Breakneck
speed when UBS under duress finally
makes an offer on Sunday morning it
lands like a lead balloon credits visas
insulted they've essentially offered a
billion dollars allegedly
um you know and that is just a fraction
of the market cap that was around eight
billion dollars on Friday and just you
know peanuts compared to what Credit
Suisse was valued at in its Heyday by
the evening a deal was in place UBS
would pay 3 billion Swiss Francs about
3.3 billion dollars controversially the
agreement imposes 16 billion francs of
losses on a category of bondholders that
is supposed to be paid before
shareholders that might make it harder
for banks to raise emergency capital in
future meaning the entire banking sector
could still end up paying a price for
credit suisse's transgressions with the
era of cheap money coming to a close the
global economy and terminal and investor
confidence scarce the condition prove
too much for a bank that never really
learned its lesson from the global
financial crisis
foreign